يعزل الرجل الثاني في البلاد وهو
رئيس الوزراء مع ثلاثة اخرين
له بريطانيا. ليضيف اردوجان ان
موقف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
حد تعبيره. الاحداث والتطورات.
بعد من التلويح والتهديد.
من اجل الجمال او الرشاقة بل
بسبب التضخم الاقتصادي الذي وصلت
سلطنة عمان لم تسمح لشركات
الطيران الاسرائيلي بالتحليق فوق
من الطرفين. واوضح قائد القوات
البحرية في الحرس الثوري
الامريكية لاطلاق تحذير مسموع
واطلاق شعلة تحذيرية كذلك. لكن
وصفته البحرية الامريكية بانه
خطير وغير امن. ما دعا السفن
الايراني علي رضا تنكسيري ان هذه
المواجهات حصلت من خلال الزوارق
وان لم تحقق المطلوب عندها ستغير
من ادواتها. وهكذا يمضي الصينيون
الروس سد فستغلق قضية الامداد
المائي والكهربائي لشبه جزيرة
ايران. حيث كشف الحرس الثوري
الايراني عن وقوع مواجهات بحرية
الاوكرانية احتمالية انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي في جميع انحاء
اي كتل عسكرية معادية لها الى
اراض سابقة لها. ويقصد هنا
وذلك وسط انقسام بالاراء لتأتي
لهم روسيا بالحل. وقالت المكاتب
اوكرانيا وانضمامها الناتو. ومن
تهديدات ميدفيديف المخيفة الى
يقصد انها ستكون النهاية لمجلس
الامن. لكن ما الذي تنوي روسيا
مائة وعشرين عسكريا اوكرانيا فعن
اي ارقام نتحدث ومع احتدام
منطقة خرسون فقد اعلنت اوكرانيا
عن استعادة ثمان وثمانين بلدة من
المعارك الميدانية وغزارة
الهجمات المسيرة دعت بريطانيا
السابق ويا لها من اخبار سارة
للغرب والعالم اجمع. اردوغان زاد
استعدادا لدى بوتين وزينسكي
لتمديد سريان اتفاق الحبوب.
القادة ليعلنها الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان قائلا لمست
المعارك الاوكرانية محملين بهدية
لوالدهم وهي ثلاثة رجال اسرى من
الجيش الاوكراني يا لهؤلاء
الاطفال المجانين كانوا في ارض
اي رحمة. ووفق وسائل اعلامية
غربية. فقد غير حكومته لينطلق في
اليوم ومن المناورات الكلامية
الى ارض المعركة الواقعية.
اللوم على الاخر وكل يغني على
ليلاه. فهل سيتم تفجير السد حقا?
روسيا تخطط لاغراق خرسون كلها
بتفجير سد كاخوفكا. وكانت روسيا
عانوا من القنابل النووية منذ
الحرب العالمية الثانية وحتى
امريكا تعلن التحدي. ما عاد
بالامكان الصبر اكثر مما كان.
في هذه الاحداث كطرف ثالث.
وخلقوا لروسيا تهديدات
قديروف يعودون من ارض المعركة
بهدية لوالدهم. وسد خرسون على
القديمة القائمة على الغزو
والمواجهة. فهل بدأت النتائج
لجأوا لتقنين وجباتهم اليومية
لتصبح وجبتين فقط في اليوم ليس
تحذيرا شديد اللهجة لمجلس الامن
الدولي. والروس يسخرون من الغرب
ولبنان يطرد لا سوريا وعمان تمنع
اسرائيل من المرور فوق سمائها.
وارتفاع اسعار المطاعم الجامعية.
امريكا تريد ان تعلن عن عودتها
السوريين هذا الاسبوع. فهل سيقبل
اللاجئون بالعودة طوعيا الى
بوتين بشأن المفاوضات مع الجانب
الاوكراني اصبح اكثر مرونة من
الطوابير ليست امام المحطات فقط
بل يصطف اليوم طلاب الجامعات في
بلادهم ام ان السلطات اللبنانية
ستضطر الى اعادتهم قسرا? اذاعة
بالظهور فورا? تركيا لا تلعب.
عندما وجد الطريق مفتوحا امامه
الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من عشر
رحلات جوية الى الهند الغيت لان
ولسان حال الغرب يقول ليتك
تفعلها يا اردوغان وتخرجنا من
طوابير لامتار والهدف الحصول على
طعام مجاني وذلك بسبب التضخم
اشهر طاردت زوارق ايرانية سفنا
امريكية في مضيق هرمز بمشهد
لقيادة العالم كيف سيواجه
الامريكان كل هذه الجبهات التي
اراضيها. كفو يا الذيب ها الموقف
يبغى له شيلة. لنكمل وفي فرنسا
تقرير نشرته البي بي سي يفيد بان
هناك الكثير من البريطانيين
الغذاء هذه. فما عدنا نطيق
الجوع. وبمناسبة الجوع هناك
السلطات اللبنانية تعلن عن نيتها
البدء في عملية اعادة اللاجئين
في الاتجاه الايجابي. مضيفا ان
امريكا ليست الخيار الوحيد على
على تعديل دستور الحزب والذي
سيعزز مكانة كزعيم للصين. ها هو
حمية قليلا واعلن ان بيع امريكا
طائرات اف ستة عشر لتركيا يسير
حفيد عثمان وصل مضيه سالكا جميع
السبل لوضع قدم له بين كبار
تحقيق اهدافها بطرق اخرى اسرع
مما مضى. بينما اجهز الحزب مادة
الصيني لا يتوقف يخطط ويدبر
فتظهر النتائج على ارض الواقع
وبطريقة مخزية ومخجلة تم طردهم
من المجلس واخراجهم بالقوة وبدون
لماذا لم يتحدث الامريكان عن
بقية الحادثة? وبرأيكم هل
دليل يؤكد الحادثة. نترك الاجابة
لكم. الصين تغير جلدها. العقل
البحرية العسكرية السريعة وقال
ان قوات خسرت خلال المواجهات
التمثيلية للبيوت الروسية وهي
السفارة المتواجدة في الدول
الى الامام دون ان ينظر ورائهم.
بعد ان وافق مؤتمر الحزب الشيوعي
مباشرة مع القوات الامريكية خلال
الاشهر الماضية وسقوط قتلى وجرحى
طهران تكشف عن مواجهات بحرية مع
واشنطن اخفتها امريكا واظهرتها
هجومية الى اوكرانيا دولية. فهل
عرفتم ما هي هذه الاعتبارات?
طائرات مسيرة ايرانية لمهاجمة
اوكرانيا لتؤكد السلطات
التوصل الى قرار نهائي بشأن
تحديد سقف اسعار الغاز الروسي
القرم? مواجهة عسكرية مع امريكا.
تحذيرات امريكا ما عادت تخيف.
لسخرية الاقدار. تهديدات روسيا
ليست للغرب فقط. هنا وزير الدفاع
وكذلك اسلحتها ومن كثر خصومه قلت
قوته وتشتت افكاره وخططه. هنا
نعم. انها التهديدات الروسية.
وبين هذا وذاك تظهر مشكلة عويصة
ليخرج سكرتير الامن القومي
الاوكراني ويحذر من انه اذا فجر
قاعة الاتحاد الاوروبي. هناك فشل
قادة اوروبا للمرة الرابعة في
الفيتو الدولي. بمتر ميدفيديف
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
تشمل صامويل فيف روبرتس وسانجري
ومروحيتين وكالة سبأ نيوز. وقبل
التصريحات الايرانية واقعية? اذا
لماذا لم ينشروا اي فيديو او
القرم والى الابد حسب تعبيره.
فما هو هدفكم القادم بعد جسر
اربعة من هذه الزوارق لكن
الامريكيين خسروا ثلاثة طردات
قد اتهمت كييف بقصف السد
بالصواريخ والتخطيط لتدميره كل
فعله يا ترى? ومن جانب اخر اضاف
ميدفيديف بما ان روسيا هي وريثة
في اوكرانيا وبالتحديد في خرسون.
حيث قالت صحيفة التليجراف ان
وفرنسا والمانيا الامم المتحدة
الى التحقيق في استخدام روسيا
هناك ايضا شرب الشاي واعادة شحن
هواتفكم وها مشاهدة افلامكم. يا
الغربية انها ستفتح كنقاط تدفئة
للاوروبيين واضافت ساخرة يمكنكم
المعركة فعلا ام انهم ذهبوا
ليلعبوا الفوجي هناك. واما في
يطمئن الحلفاء في المنطقة من
تجارب كوريا الشمالية النووية
بينما عاد اطفال قاديروف الثلاثة
الى بلادهم وذلك بعد مشاركتهم في
الامبراطورية الروسية والاتحاد
السوفيتي فهي لن تتسامح مع دخول
الروسية احباط هجمات للقوات
الاوكرانية في خرسون والقضاء على
منشآت الطاقة عن الخدمة. ومن
المعارك الجوية الى معركة نقض
البلاد بسبب القصف الروسي وذلك
بعد خروج نحو اربعين بالمائة من
القوات الروسية. لكن في المقابل
قد نفت روسيا لتعلن وزارة الدفاع
ولا زلنا في شرق اسيا حيث الدولة
الوحيدة التي تعرضت لقنبلة ذرية
الميكانيكي ثمانية وعشرين للجيش
الاوكراني بحسب وكالة سبوتنيك.
الشمالية كلا على فهل تملك
الولايات المتحدة قوة تكفي
تايوان بدعوة القيادة الصينية
الجديدة الى التخلي عن عقليتها
على الاطلاق. نعم انها اليابان
هنا رئيس وزرائها فوميو كيشيدا
واضحة على الاستعداد المباشر
لعدوان وشيك فان خطر القوات
تنص على المواجهة الحازمة
لانفصال تايوان. لترد السلطات في
يحذر من ان استخدام روسيا
للاسلحة النووية سينظر اليه على
مظليون روس يدمرون الكتيبة
الالية الاولى من اللواء
انه عمل عدائي ضد الانسانية
واصفا تهديد الرئيس الروسي
بالقرب من حدود بلاده. واضاف
بانه بالرغم من عدم وجود مؤشرات
عسكريا غير مسبوق للقوات
الامريكية وحلف الناتو يتواجد
ون بي بعيدة المدى في جزيرة جوان
في المحيط الهادئ كسلاح رادع
ومن محاولة الصين غزوة تايوان.
فماذا ان استمرت بكين وبيونج
المنتشرة على الحدود ما زال فما
الذي يخطط له الامريكان؟ قلقوا
فلاديمير بوتين بانه جدي ومقلق
للغاية. فليصغي الغرب لتحذير من
يانج بخططهما؟ هل تعلن واشنطن
وكيف سيرد اصحاب العيون الضيقة؟
بلاروسيا يعززه قلق في اسيا. حيث
تنشر الولايات المتحدة قاذفات بي
لمقارعة كل هؤلاء هنا وزير
الدفاع البلاروسي. يقول ان حشدا
الاسرائيلي. نساعد اوكرانيا
انسانيا لكن لن نرسل اسلحة
واشنطن وجها لوجه امام اقوى
منافسيها روسيا والصين وكوريا
ووقوع خسائر من الطرفين. فما
الذي يجري واردوجان يبشر
المارد الامريكي يخرج من قمقمه
ويعلن التحدي ويا له من تحد سيضع
بهذه الطريقة المضحكة. وايران
تكشف عن مواجهات بحرية مع امريكا
يظهر متوعدا بان تواجه المنظمة
مصير ما كان يعرف بعصبة الامم
وشك الانفجار. فمن سيضغط زر
التفجير يا ترى. موسكو تطلق
الولايات المتحدة تنشر جنودها
قرب بلاروسيا وتضع قاذفتها في
الاوكرانيين ويحذر امريكا وبكين
تجري تغييرات على جلد حكومتها
ضد روسيا والصين وكوريا الشمالية
في وقت واحد عن اي جنون يتحدث
وقوية.
المحيط الهادئ. جن جنون
الامريكان. هل قررت واشنطن الحرب
استراتيجية غير مقبولة. يجب ان
يعرفوا ان ضرباتنا ستكون سريعة
يفتحونها في وقت واحد هذا ما
سيتضح خلال الفترة القادمة.